la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y en a
t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues j'ai le plaisir de
saluer dans la tribune d'honneur une
délégation conduite par Madame Brigitte
boccolettage présidente du conseil
national de Monaco elle est accompagnée
par notre collègue Dominique Estrosi
Sassone président du groupe inter
parlementaire d'amitié France Monaco
cette visite s'inscrit dans le cadre des
échanges réguliers entre le Sénat et la
Principauté de Monaco dont les liens
avec la France ont si étroit en
particulier pour nos concitoyens du
département des Alpes-Maritimes qui
travaillent quotidiennement nombreux
cette visite aura permis d'évoquer les
nombreux sujets intéressants directement
les relations franco Monégasques en
particulier le logement les transports
l'environnement
l'environnement dans le domaine dans
lequel la Principauté est à
l'avant-garde mais aussi des
négociations avec l'Union européenne
pour la conclusion éventuelle d'un
accord d'association nous souhaitons à
nos amis Monégasques de fructuer
échanges en formulant le vœu cette
session de travail interne parlementaire
contribue à renforcer davantage des
relations entre nos deux états
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
des nuits d'une rare violence sont
marquées notre pays depuis une semaine
les mers les élus locaux en première
ligne ont été encore une fois le rempart
de la République
aux côtés de nos forces de l'ordre de
nos sapeurs-pompiers et de nos polices
municipales
la mort d'un jeune est évidemment un
drame mais rien ne peut justifier les
émeutes les agressions et menaces contre
les élus le pillage l'incendie de nos
mairies de nos écoles de le commissariat
ou de commerce
l'ordre républicain doit être établi et
les enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
devront être tirés
le Sénat s'y engagera pleinement dans sa
mission temps de législateur comme de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
afin que soient faite la lumière sur ces
événements qu'on soit tirés les
enseignants les enseignements et que
nous puissions faciliter faciliter pour
nos élus locaux le redressement de
situation aujourd'hui insupportable
enfin mes chers collègues je veux en
autre nom à tous apporter notre soutien
à tous ceux citoyens commerçants élus
locaux force de sécurité de secours qui
ont été visés ou directement atteints
par ces violences voilà la déclaration
que je souhaitais faire avant que nous
abordions notre ordre du jour notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre quatre jours de
violence et d'émeutes quatre jours de
vol et de pillage 4 jours d'agression et
d'incendie qu'est-ce que cette situation
dit de notre société
j'ai vu avec peine le départ de bande
dans lequel je suis élu le quartier dans
lequel j'ai grandi et où je vis devenir
dans quelques heures le champ de
bataille de quelques voyous
avant tout permettez-moi de saluer les
mers des Hauts-de-Seine de toute
sensibilité politique et à travers eux
l'ensemble des maires de France qui ont
été en première ligne comme toujours les
élus locaux n'ont pas failli
et ils ont même été et éviter que tout
s'enflamme davantage bien sûr il y a eu
un drame la mort d'un jeune de 17 ans
qui nous a forcément ému et choqué la
justice fera son travail elle le fait
déjà vite et elle le fait bien mais la
justice ce n'est pas la vengeance la
justice ce n'est pas attaquée et blessé
près de 800 policiers gendarmes et
pompiers la justice ce n'est pas
détruire et incendier des crèches nos
écoles nos bibliothèques et nos mairies
la justice ce n'est pas pillée les
magasins et même brûler nos voitures
la justice ce n'est pas menacée la vie
des élus et de leur famille comme ce fut
le cas pour notre collègue Jean Brun
qui peut encore accepter que certains
prônent le chaos et l'insurrection
permanente pour gagner un pouvoir qui
n'ont pas réussi à obtenir par les urnes
les auteurs de ces attaques ne sont pas
des simples jeunes la jeunesse de notre
pays celle de nos quartiers ne mérite
pas cette définition son écrasante
majorité travail elle est courageuse
elle est audacieuse elle est solidaire
et elle se bat au quotidien pour prendre
cette ascenseur social non ces individus
ne sont ni des insurgés ni des insoumis
ils ont fait le choix de la violence non
pas fatalité mais par facilité face à
cette violence il nous faut donc de la
fermeté de l'ordre et de la justice il
est temps Madame la première ministre de
refonder notre pacte républicain autour
des valeurs de solidarité de mérite
d'ordre et de travail d'avoir ce sursaut
civique qui est nécessaire pour notre
pays cela ne se fera pas sans les élus
locaux qui ont plus que jamais besoin de
la République besoin de l'État à leur
côté madame la Première ministre quels
moyens le gouvernement compte mettre en
place pour les soutenir je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole des Kev
Adams la première ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Xavier yakovelli
la mort tragique d'un jeune homme de 17
ans dans votre département à Nanterre a
provoqué une émotion légitime dans notre
pays et je sais qu'elle a été partagée
dans cette émission
mais cette émotion ne peut pas servir de
prétexte pour des violences
inacceptables pour viser les symboles de
la République brûler des mairies des
commissariats ou des écoles pour piller
des magasins pour cibler des élus et
j'ai de nouveau une pensée pour le maire
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et pour sa famille
avec chacun d'entre vous j'en suis sûr
je veux à nouveau dire mon soutien aux
policiers gendarmes policiers municipaux
et sapeurs-pompiers engagés avec courage
et professionnalisme je veux saluer la
mobilisation des magistrats et des
greffiers je veux dire au maire et aux
élus qui sont en première ligne que nous
sommes à leur côté notre première
priorité notre priorité absolue c'est le
retour de l'ordre républicain notre
stratégie s'est appuyée sur quatre
piliers d'abord la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre avec jusqu'à 45 000
policiers et gendarmes sur le terrain
ensuite la fermeté de la réponse pénale
pour qu'il n'y ait aucune impunité à
l'égard des auteurs de violence
troisième pilier la responsabilisation
des réseaux sociaux et enfin un rappel
nécessaire de la responsabilité et de
l'autorité parentale car les auteurs
sont jeunes voire très jeunes
une décrue de la violence a été observée
ces dernières nuits et la situation
devient redevient pratiquement normale
bien sûr avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin nous restons extrêmement
vigilants et nous adaptons très
progressivement notre dispositif de
sécurité
monsieur le sénateur yakovelli si
l'urgence est au rétablissement de
l'ordre républicain nous sommes d'ores
et déjà mobilisés auprès des élus et des
mers pour les accompagner dans la
réparation de leur ville le Président de
la République l'a dit hier nous
accompagnerons les élus touchés
notamment au plan financier et en
accélérant les procédures pour réouvrir
au plus vite les équipements publics et
nous répondrons présents pour les
habitants pour les commerçants les
artisans pour toutes les victimes de ces
violences
monsieur le sénateur si l'urgence est au
rétablissement de l'ordre républicain
cette crise appelle des réponses de
fonds elle nécessite un diagnostic
partagé et une action collective de
l'État et de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et je ne doute pas que le
Sénat y prendra toute sa part je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
Durand pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la semaine
dernière un enfant est mort cette mort
est tragique et nous pensons la douleur
de la famille de Naël cette mort a eu
des conséquences collectives terribles
des quartiers se sont embrasés partout
en France en Île-de-France dans de
grandes villes comme dans de plus
petites communes nos forces de l'ordre
ont rétabli calme et il faut les en
remercier une colère au début
compréhensible s'est transformé
progressivement en N aveugle propice au
pillage les sénateurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices socialistes ont évidemment
appelé au calme la République ne peut
pas exister sans ordre mais elle ne peut
pas reposer que sur l'ordre le concours
Lépine des postures autoritaires nous
laissent entre la colère et les béthes
deux claques et au lit une cagnotte par
ci une milice par là une dose de
régression ethnique c'est l'incendie
après l'incendie
la question que je souhaite vous poser
s'adresse à vous puisque vous êtes au
responsabilités mais nous avons tous à y
répondre une grande partie de la
jeunesse paix aujourd'hui notre échec
collectif à faire rayonner la République
nous n'avons pas désamorcé les bombes
plantées dans les fondations de notre
société les causes en sont multiples et
variées certains refusent constipent
mais si nous ne nous posons pas les
bonnes questions nous ne trouverons pas
les justes réponse les questions qui
sont posées sont légion la politique de
la ville les discriminations le rôle des
mers difficile en première ligne je veux
pour ma part vous interroger sur ce qui
a mis le feu aux poudres les relations
entre police et population fin 2020
Beauveau de la sécurité était convoqué
sur ces sujets si des choses utiles en
sont sorties pour la police et nous
avons voté la loopnie force et de
constater que toute la population est
loin d'être réconciliée avec sa police
ce ministre comment comptez-vous
désormais améliorer concrètement cette
question des rapports entre police et
population
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
des outre-merdes ce Gérald Darmanin
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du Rhin
à Nanterre il y a eu un drame et je
crois que les premiers mots que j'ai pu
avoir comme ministre de l'intérieur
comme la première ministre évidemment
était des mots de transparence
d'équilibre parce que si on soutient les
forces de l'ordre et vous je pense que
vous voyez et vous soutenez également
les forces de l'ordre comme nous le
faisons il faut savoir dire les choses
et ne pas mentir aux Français la justice
passe ce policier qui a toujours la
présomption d'innocence je souhaite le
souligner a été mis en garde à vue a été
mis en examen il existe donc des indices
graves et concordants comme quoi il se
responsable de la mort en dehors de la
loi de la République en dehors de la
déontologie de ce jeune homme il est en
détention provisoire je veux aussi en
disant ça avoir une pensée pour les 800
policiers gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers
blessés pendant ces quatre jours
d'émeutes et qui ont été courageux et à
la hauteur de ce que la nation leur
offre comme confiance et je veux ici le
souligner
bien sûr on peut toujours améliorer le
travail de la police et de la
gendarmerie monsieur le sénateur et
évidemment il y a toujours des efforts à
faire mais est-ce que le comportement de
la police comme je l'entends parfois
depuis plusieurs heures est-ce la seule
réponse aux difficultés que nous
connaissons et s la seule réponse aux
violences si c'est le cas pourquoi on a
attaqué des sapeurs-pompiers il ne
contrôle personne il sauve tout le monde
pourquoi on a attaqué des polices
municipales
78 poses de police municipales la police
municipale ne sont pas sur la même
consigne que pour la police pour la
gendarmerie nationale pourquoi on
attaque des élus est-ce que ces élus ont
tutoyé ces délinquants ont-ils été
particulièrement discriminants pourquoi
ont-ils attaqué des médiathèques des
écoles pourquoi ont-ils payer des
commerces ne trouvons pas des excuses
toujours dans le comportement de la
police si elle doit se réformer
elle doit aussi
si elle doit se réformer monsieur Durand
et je sais que je parle à la République
et doit aussi être d'éviter être un bouc
émissaire pour se poser les bonnes
questions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez quelques secondes vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question je vous la
reposerai en édition tout à l'heure
alors que des vents mauvais des vents
sécuritaires souffle alors que certains
des syndicats policiers s'égarent dans
des tracts inquiétants nous vous
demandons Monsieur le Ministre de tenir
bon sur les principes républicains de la
police de la République
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut pas demander davantage au
maire déjà beaucoup exposé ce n'est pas
non plus le président de la République
seul à l'Élysée qui pourra régler du
règlement les problèmes ni croire que le
rappel alors des parents certes
nécessaires sera suffisant c'est en
conjuguant toutes nos forces que l'on
s'en sortira état Région Département
knaf CNAM knav Action Logement chambre
consulaire Caisse des Dépôts monde du
HLM secteur privé associatif c'est la
grande coalition proposée par Jean-Louis
Borloo chevet des piliers fondamentaux
que sont la justice l'ordre public la
jeunesse la santé l'habitat l'énergie la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
il nous faut un chef de fil pour chacun
des 19 programmes du plan Borlo et un
pilote pour le suivi régulier l'or n'est
plus au rapport d'experts leur est à
l'action
vous avez dit hier madame la Première
ministre est à l'écoute des propositions
et bien elles sont faites comment
comptez-vous maintenant effectivement
les mettre en œuvre
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du Logement monsieur Klein merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fialer oui vous avez raison le
message doit être porté par l'Ensemble
de notre pays d'abord un message pour le
retour au calme et c'était le la
première des priorités et ensuite comme
vous l'avez dit nous devons continuer à
travailler ensemble pour les quartiers
populaires vous rappelez le travail mené
par Jean-Luc Borlo et son rapport un
certain nombre d'entre vous il y avait
d'ailleurs contribué moi-même j'ai
participé à son écriture et je peux vous
assurer on va pas peser ça au trébuchet
mais la réalité c'est que un grand
nombre des propositions de ce rapport
ont été mis en oeuvre la première c'est
la relance de l'Agence Nationale pour le
renouvellement urbain lors du
quinquennat précédent nous sommes passés
de 5 milliards à 12 milliards pour les
quartiers populaires ça veut dire que
tous les acteurs vont dépenser près de
50 milliards pour ces quartiers avec un
retour
[Musique]
avec le gouvernement et un ensemble des
élus locaux et je vous remercie monsieur
Fiolet vous avez quelques secondes
oui monsieur le ministre je vous ai bien
entendu écouter il faut vraiment qu'on
ait un pilote dans de tous ces actions
que chaque
chantier soit aussi avec un chef de fil
parce que c'est ensemble que l'on pourra
s'en sortir
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
broyer pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire de la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre Naël a été abattu à
bout portant il avait 17 ans il est mort
et c'est inacceptable le domicile du
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses a été attaqué
mettant danger la vie de son épouse et
de ses enfants c'est un qualifiable
chaque jour habitant et commerçant élus
et agents des services publics font le
bilan des dégâts dans leur ville
réparent ce qu'ils peuvent et disent
leurs interrogations et leur refus de la
violence les mers font face comme
toujours monsieur le ministre qui peut
croire qu'il suffit d'appeler à
l'autorité à la répression à la mise en
cause des familles pour tourner la page
nous devons comprendre les causes ne pas
comprendre c'est se rendre incapable de
traiter les problèmes ouvrons les yeux
et regardons ces quartiers qui malgré
les milliards consacrés à la rénovation
urbaine reste souvent des quartiers de
relégation on a mis beaucoup d'argent
dans le bâti mais pas assez dans
l'humain quelle faute d'avoir enterré le
plan Borlo 57% d'enfants vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté 18% vraiment solo deux
enfants sur trois ne partiront pas en
vacances dans les quartiers prioritaires
les hommes naissent libres égaux dans
notre République mais c'est moins vrai
quand on est pauvre noir ou arabe
ouvrons les yeux sur le racisme et les
discriminations qui rongent notre
société comment accepter qu'une grande
partie de la jeunesse et de la police se
regardent en ennemi c'est ce qui a fait
courir c'est ce qui a fait courir
zayette bounaï muettin vers ce
transformateur électrique en 2005 le
racisme et la peur sont toujours là pas
chez tous bien sûr mais toujours là
quand même monsieur le ministre
convoquons l'intelligence collective au
chevet de notre République malade celle
de tous ceux qui croient que la promesse
républicaine est là pour tous la
promesse républicaine a trop souvent
quitté nos quartiers comment dire aux
enfants des quartiers en difficulté
qu'ils sont toutes et tous les filles et
les fils de la République disaient le
président Chirac en 2005 monsieur le
ministre prendrez-vous l'initiative
et la responsabilité d'un travail
collectif indispensable ou reculons nous
une fois de plus devant l'obstacle
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur brûlé
ces émeutes se sont pas celles de 2005
vous avez utilisé les mots du président
Chirac vous avez convoqué ce qui a été à
l'origine d'une politique de la ville de
la création de la rue et de choses qui
ont été partagées de manière unanime
553 communes ont été victimes de
dégradation un titre à un autre 169
d'entre elles ne sont pas en géographie
politique de la ville dans 120 d'entre
elles il y a moins de 3000 habitants qui
vivent en qpv résumé ça au sujet des
quartiers c'est commencer à se tromper
sur l'analyse vous avez évoqué le bilan
et le fait qu'il fallait qu'on ouvre les
yeux je nous invite à ouvrir les yeux
sur les 838 policiers gendarmes les
pompiers blessés depuis le début des
émeutes je nous invite à ouvrir les yeux
sur les 2500 bâtiments publics qui ont
subi des incendies je nous invite à
ouvrir des yeux sur les prêts de 4000
interpellés avec une moyenne d'âge de 17
ans
ouvrir les yeux c'est se demander
comment des enfants de 13 à 14 ans
peuvent se retrouver la nuit avec des
bidons d'essence dans les mains à
incendier des bâtiments publics ouvrir
les yeux c'est se demander comment des
mortiers d'artifice peuvent être
utilisés pour viser comment on peut
tirer avec un œuf mm sur un policier à
Nîmes comment certains peuvent devant
cette situation non pas appeler à
l'autorité mais refusé d'appeler au
calme si on ouvre les yeux là-dessus on
peut parler de la suite la suite c'est
quoi la suite c'est prendre un minimum
de temps avant le fait que chacun
ressorte du placard la suggestion qu'il
avait faite lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle pour regarder ce que
cette géographie entraîne
on ne peut pas imaginer que le sujet
c'est seulement un problème d'argent
public et de milliards d'euros et on ne
peut pas non plus penser que on peut
résumer ce débat à celui des allocations
familiales surtout ces sujets prendre le
temps du diagnostic pour ensuite être
capable d'agir c'est nécessaire et
laissez-moi vous dire une chose
stigmatiser les quartiers c'est laisser
penser que ils sont enfermés de manière
immuable il y a dans ces quartiers des
gens qui en sont sortis il y en a
d'autres qui sont rentrés on n'est pas
sur une logique de photos on est sur une
logique d'évolution et si on ne prend
pas ça en compte on se trompe là aussi
sur le diagnostic
mais si la parole
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant au président Claude malure
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre les
violences de ces derniers jours ont été
condamnés par la quasi-totalité des
formations politiques seul une fois de
plus l'une d'entre elles s'en est
exemptées en refusant d'appeler au calme
les dirigeants de la France soumis à
l'émeute confirme qu'ils sont bien
confirment qu'ils sont bien les ânes de
Troie du séparatisme dans notre pays en
demandant qu'on épargne les
bibliothèques et les écoles ils
autorisent des émeutiers à brûler tout
le reste les commerces les mairies les
maisons des élus ils prétendent défendre
la République leur but est de la faire
tomber depuis un an leur convulsion à
l'Assemblée nationale les discrédites en
discréditant et l'associent le Parlement
cette fois-ci c'est la foi de trop et le
peuple français qu'il prétendent à tort
incarner s'en souviendra longtemps tout
comme son souviendront sans doute leur
plus proche alliés politiques désormais
honteux de cette alliance contre nature
quant aux protestations faussement
scandalisée des despote de Turquie
d'Algérie ou d'Iran où la répression de
tels émeutes aurait sans aucun doute
fait des dizaines voire des centaines de
victimes permettez-moi de dire qu'elle
donne la nausée enfin la responsabilité
des réseaux antisociaux dans la
propagation des violences est-elle que
le Président de la République a dû les
convoquer à l'Élysée Barack Obama disait
que ces réseaux sont devenus l'une des
principales menaces contre nos
démocraties la preuve est là vous avez
madame la Première ministre condamnée
hier à l'Assemblée l'attitude d'un parti
anti-démocratique sans statut sans
élection interne gouvernée par un
satrape colérique et omnipotent traitant
ses dissidents par la mise à l'écart en
disant qu'il était sorti du champ
républicain et vous avez eu raison
pouvez-vous nous dire aujourd'hui si
vous envisagez de mettre de l'ordre dans
la jungle des plateformes qu'il faut
empêcher d'invoquer à tort la liberté
d'expression pour se rendre complice des
appels à l'émeutes et de l'apologie des
violences et si vous comptez demander à
la ministre des Affaires étrangères de
protest er contre les ingérences de
dictateurs qui se permettent de nous
donner des leçons de démocratie
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la Première ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Claude madurée monsieur le
Président Claude
le drame de la mort d'un jeune homme de
17 ans ne peut justifier ou excuser
aucune violence
comme la famille du jeune homme comme
les élus du territoire concerné nous ne
demandons qu'une chose la justice et
jamais la justice n'est venu de la
violence
depuis une semaine des actes
inacceptables ont touché plusieurs
centaines de communes les forces de
l'ordre les sapeurs-pompiers et des élus
ont été pris pour cible des mairies des
écoles des équipements publics ont été
vandalisés parfois incendiées des
commerces ont été pillés
face à cette situation nous avons tout
mis en oeuvre pour rétablir l'ordre
républicain autour d'un mot d'ordre le
refus de l'impunité c'est ce que nous
demande les habitants des quartiers
touchés ils sont les premières victimes
de ces violences et les près de 6
millions d'habitants des quartiers n'ont
rien à voir avec quelques milliers de
délinquants
depuis le début des violences près de
4000 personnes ont été interpellées le
Garde des Sceaux a demandé au procureur
une réponse rapide ferme et systématique
pour tous les auteurs et hier soir au
total près de 1000 personnes avec déjà
été présentées à la justice et plus de
350 sont déjà en détention la réponse
pénale a été forte avec notamment des
peines de prison ferme avec des
incarcérations
j'ajoute que le garde des sceaux vient
de diffuser une circulaire sur le
traitement des infractions commises par
les mineurs et les conditions
d'engagement de la responsabilité de
leurs parents
monsieur le Président maluré évidemment
dans cette crise les réseaux sociaux
jouent un rôle important il facilite
parfois l'organisation des violences et
ont souvent une responsabilité dans la
désinhibition des jeunes c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement a demandé à l'ensemble
des plateformes de respecter leurs
obligations de retrait des contenus
illicites et d'être vigilants sur
certaines de leurs fonctionnalités comme
la géolocalisation
par ailleurs nous veillons à ce que les
titulaires des contes ayant participé à
des violences soit identifiées et
poursuivi d'autres réponses de plus long
terme devront être importés c'est
notamment l'objet du règlement européen
sur les services numériques et du projet
de loi pour sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique examiner en ce moment
même au Sénat je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant président Bruno
retaillod pour le groupe les
républicains
vous avez raison Madame la première
ministre une mort tragique ne veut pas
servir de prétexte et cette vie de
violence ces nuits de chaos nous impose
une double exigence une double réponse
la première c'est pour maintenant que la
République servait en
et ensuite pour demain que le
gouvernement ouvre grand les yeux serrez
les rangs parce que dans la mesure où
l'ordre public n'est pas revenu et tant
qu'il ne sera pas réétabli la seule
attitude républicaine responsable cette
sérénérant c'est de soutenir sans
réserve les forces de l'ordre policiers
nationaux municipaux les
sapeurs-pompiers et les élus bien
entendu
mais
c'est aussi de laisser le gouvernement
travailler et le ministre d'intérieur
pour établir l'ordre public l'ordre
républicain en France et nous sommes
d'accord comme vous madame je condamne
aussi ces élus de l'extrême gauche qui
ont choisi leur camp ce camp qui n'est
pas celui de la République ce camp qui
est celui des émeutiers ce sont des
professionnels de l'excuse sociale mais
en l'occurrence ils n'ont strictement
aucune excuse et puis pour l'avenir
l'important pour le gouvernement ce sera
d'ouvrir grand les yeux d'établir le bon
diagnostic d'appeler un chat un chat un
émeutier ça n'est pas un déshérité un
délai un délinquant ça n'est pas une
victime alors madame la Première
ministre deux questions la première
quels sont pour vous les causes de ces
émeutes
la seconde quelles sont les remèdes
sachant que et vous le savez très bien
la France tranquille
n'accepte plus de passer à la caisse
pour des minorités qui saccagent leur
quartier
parole est abordable la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
président Bruno Retailleau
face aux violences inexcusable qui ont
touché plusieurs centaines de communes
depuis une semaine
notre premier objectif a été le retour
de l'ordre républicain
nous avons mis en place des moyens
exceptionnels et grâce à la mobilisation
rapide de l'état grâce à l'action et au
courage des forces de l'ordre et des
sapeurs-pompiers grâce à la mobilisation
des élus locaux notamment des mers les
violences connaissent depuis quelques
jours une très forte décrue et la
situation revient progressivement à la
normale
face à la crise nous avions un devoir
d'unité et je veux saluer monsieur le
Président l'attitude républicaine de
votre famille politique pour dénoncer
les violences et appeler au calme
bien sûr monsieur le Président
Retailleau au delà des réponses
d'urgence nous devons nous pencher sur
les causes profondes de cette crise
sans procrastiner il faudra prendre la
mesure de la complexité de la réalité
un tiers des communes qui ont connu des
violences n'ont pas de quartier
politique de la ville et la moitié des
villes avec des grands ensembles où sont
menés des opérations lourdes de
rénovation urbaine n'ont pas connu de
violence monsieur le Président
Retailleau la quasi-totalité des prêts
de 6 millions d'habitants des quartiers
qui sont les premières victimes de ces
violences expriment leur incompréhension
et leur colère j'ai pu le mesurer
moi-même à Garges-lès-Gonesse à Évry ou
à Bezons ils aspirent à la sécurité ils
aspirent à des services publics de
qualité ils aspirent à être des acteurs
de la République sans distinction
d'origine comme le garantie l'article
premier de notre Constitution
monsieur le Président ensemble nous
devrons nous interroger sur le respect
de l'autorité sur l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale sur l'influence des
réseaux sociaux sur la désinhibie
désinhibition face à la violence ou
encore sur l'efficacité de nos
politiques publiques nous mènerons ces
réflexions sans a priori sans excès ni
caricature sans tabou ni bouc émissaire
nous le ferons avec tous les élites qui
veulent agir et partagent les valeurs de
la République cet ensemble que nous
trouverons des solutions je vous
remercie
le président
oui madame la ministre ma première
ministre le temps nous est compté et les
causes nous les connaissons c'est la
somme de tous nos renoncements c'est la
somme de tous les laisser aller la
faille de l'école la faillite l'autorité
parentale le chaos migratoire bien sûr
le chaos migratoire et aussi une réponse
pénale qui pour les mineurs pour les
mineurs et souvent inadapté alors madame
la Première ministre faites la politique
du courage et il y a le courage de
traiter les causes de traiter les causes
et non pas seulement les conséquences de
ces causes par la politique du carnet de
tchèque et alors si vous avez ce courage
nous serons à vos côtés parce que sans
ce courage sans ce courage les violences
reviendront et sans se courage sans se
courage la France rebroulera
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
le Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre quand
la violence augmente cela veut dire que
la politique recule
tout sur le territoire national mais
aussi dans les quartiers l'État a
abandonné ou en tout cas mal assuré une
de ses missions régaliennes celle qui
consiste à préserver la sécurité et la
paix civile il faut en premier lieu
rétablir cette politique prioritaire
dont le succès conditionne la réussite
de toutes les autres l'objectif de la
politique de la ville vous le savez et
de restaurer l'égalité républicaine
entre les quartiers malgré l'engagement
remarquable des acteurs sur le terrain
des élus locaux force et de constater
que cette promesse n'est plus tenue le
dernier plan en faveur des quartiers qui
a été évoqué de Jean-Louis Borloo
plaçant les habitants des quartiers au
cœur de cette politique a
malheureusement été enterré dès sa
présentation depuis on ne voit se
dégager aucune stratégie certes
vous l'avez dit l'enveloppe en russe a
augmenté du bâtiment terre mais nous
sommes dans le flou sur le plan quartier
2030 et le dernier comité
interministériel des villes n'a accouché
d'aucune annonce il est urgent de faire
preuve de courage politique et
d'envisager enfin une politique sur le
long terme ce qui manque cruellement à
ce pays et cela doit commencer par
regarder la vérité en face établir un
état des lieux de la situation difficile
dans laquelle se trouve ces quartiers en
matière d'éducation d'emploi de santé de
mobilité de sécurité de logement élément
central dans l'intégration des plus
fragiles monsieur le ministre à l'heure
où les quartiers concentre toutes les
inégalités quelles sont vos intentions
pour les quartiers prioritaires à court
terme concrètement quid des contrats de
ville
2024-2030 merci
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice hunger
d'abord
Olivier Klein on en dit un mot tout à
l'heure
dire que des propositions ont été
enterrées ça suppose de regarder aussi
ce qui a été fait de manière concrète
depuis quelques années
à la minute où nous parlons ce sont 350
000 élèves qui sont non des classes des
doublées
dans ces quartiers ce sont 200 cités
éducatives c'est la plateforme pour les
stages c'est des dispositifs pour aller
lutter contre les discriminations les
assignations de résidence et de façon
concrète au-delà du passage de 5 à 12
milliards des crédits de la rue ces 2,5
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis dans
le cadre du plan de relance c'est une
augmentation de 30% des crédits du
programme 147 je vous dis tout ça en
ayant pleinement conscience qu'entre les
chiffres que je donne les montants qui
sont évoqués et la réalité des chantiers
qui ont commencé il peut y avoir des
deltas de la même manière que vous avez
invité à ce que sur les questions de
sécurité on soit capable de répondre la
loi portée par Gérald Darmanin voté par
cet assemblée 8500 policiers
supplémentaires les moyens
supplémentaires pour la justice défendue
par le garde des sceaux 8000 personnels
supplémentaires viennent d'être votées
ils sont en cours de déploiement les 200
brigades de gendarmerie commencent tout
juste à se déployer et on a un décalage
entre des annonces un constat qui a été
fait et des éléments qui sont annoncés
vous l'avez dit il y a la réflexion de
quartier de 1030 je vais pas reprendre
ni les mots de Bruno retaillod ni ceux
de la première ministre mais sans me
lever au dessus de ma condition les
miens
en quelque sorte c'est une chance que
nous ayons pu mettre sur pause pour nous
poser la question précise du diagnostic
avant de finaliser ce plan quartier 2030
parce que ce que je crois profondément
et je vous le dis un peu en tant que
ministre vautour beaucoup en tant que
ancien maire d'une ville comptant 7
quartiers politiques de la ville c'est
que si on fait des chèques et qu'on
annonce des plans avant d'aller au fond
de l'analyse des causes nous nous
tromperons et des plans qui valent sur
des années avant de les lancer il faut
qu'on soit certains que nous mettons les
moyens au bon endroit la question de
l'école et la question de l'autorité la
question de la responsabilité parentale
la question de l'association de
l'ensemble des acteurs il faut qu'on les
mette au coeur de nos réflexions tous
ensemble merci beaucoup merci de donner
la parole à Marie-Noël Lindman mais
avant de lui donner la parole je
voudrais saluer la sénatrice de Paris
depuis 2011 celle qui a poursuivi dans
notre hémicycle et au sein de la
commission des affaires économiques son
investissement sur les questions des
logements du logement qu'elle avait eu
comme ministre dans deux gouvernements
je la remercie pour son engagement comme
vice-président du Sénat chez
particulièrement apprécié de l'avoir à
mes côtés je voulais saluer son action
comme par le ventre
madame la Première ministre il est grand
temps de prendre en compte
l'exaspération de tous les Français elle
a des elle a des causes multiples des
causes sociales bien sûr d'abord sans
doute mais elle exprime aussi fortement
un grand mécontentement face aux
délitement et à l'impuissance de l'État
républicain et de nos services publics
impuissance à faire respecter les droits
le droit
impuissance à assurer l'efficacité des
services publics et leur présence
partout dans nos banlieues comme dans
les zones rurales
incapacité à faire progresser la
promesse républicaine d'égalité de
justice indispensables à la cohésion
nationale voilà le résultat d'une
politique menée depuis 20 ans
vous ne pouvez pas comme vous l'avez
fait après les gilets jaunes après le
mouvement des retraites continuez comme
avant
la grande urgence une urgence vitale et
de redonner force et efficacité à l'État
républicain au service public cela
suppose des moyens la revalorisation
elle écoute des fonctionnaires qui
désespèrent de ne pas pouvoir
correctement assumer leur mission un
exemple parmi tant d'autres tellement
d'actualité
l'éducation nationale qui ne voit
aujourd'hui l'ampleur de la crise
éducative que traverse notre pays qui ne
voit le rôle décisif de l'école publique
en particulier pour ses 20% de jeunes
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté des missions massives postes
non pourvu au concours ou dans les
classes vous ne voulez pas écouter les
enseignants vous faites croire que les
problèmes seraient en voie de résolution
ce n'est absolument pas le cas un grand
plan de redressement des services
publics s'impose et vite
allez-vous madame la Première ministre
l'engager dès cet été dans le projet
budget ne laissez pas la République en
panne agissez
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée Charlie de la ville et
du Logement monsieur Klein devait la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Marie-Noëlle
Lienemann je me permets moi aussi de
vous saluer madame la ceintatrice vous
êtes probablement la première ministre
que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie de jeune
et Lucas pour parler des copropriétés
dégradées à Clichy-sous-Bois et ça reste
dans ma mémoire
vous voyez le temps est long madame la
sénatrice
bien évidemment la question des services
publics dans les quartiers populaires
est au coeur de de notre réflexion la
mise en place des maisons France service
la mise en place des maisons de la
justice et du droit le complément qui
est fait dans l'éducation nationale dans
l'éducation prière dans la mise en place
des cités éducatives les dédoublement
des classes préparatoires des CE1 des
grandes sections et comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République dans le cadre
de quartier 2030 la scolarisation
précoce dans les écoles des quartiers
populaires le plus rapidement possible
et des moyens supplémentaires pour les
moyennes section est au cœur de nos
priorités l'action publique et vous le
savez madame la satatrice elle agit dans
nos quartiers heureusement ou en
serait-on si depuis 40 ans la politique
de la ville n'avait pas fait son œuvre
dans ses quartiers populaires vous
connaissez le travail magnifique que
fait l'Agence nationale de
renouvellement urbain aujourd'hui sur
les 453 quartiers qui ont signé leur
convention en rue plus de 450 ont
commencé des chantiers 1300 chantiers
ont été livrés parmi lesquels plus de
100 écoles l'enruence et 500 écoles qui
ont été livrées pour faire place à cette
priorité éducative dans nos quartiers
les vacances apprenantes les quartiers
d'été ont été mis en place par le
gouvernement précédent aujourd'hui un
maire qui s'en donne les moyens et qui
le souhaitent peut faire partir beaucoup
plus d'enfants dans des colonies pour la
moitié du prix qu'il le faisait avant et
je peux vous assurer que ça marche pour
y avoir
été utilisateur comme mère et pour avoir
été les visiter l'été dernier dans un
certain nombre de villes
ça marche quand les maires s'en donnent
les moyens madame la sénatrice à Sancy
et
là en l'occurrence
les mers les mers qui souhaitent
utiliser les dispositifs de l'État le
fond je vous remercie
la parole est au président Roger
caoutchi pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre donc
la République comme la démocratie sont
des régimes fragiles
nous avons ici au Parlement voté des
textes souvent votre demande sur la
sécurité sur la justice vous préparez
des textes sur l'immigration à
l'intégration est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment que ces textes suffisent pour
conforter la démocratie et la République
en France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sœurs monsieur
le ministre caoutchi
je crois que comme l'a dit la première
ministre dans la réponse à Bruno
Retailleau il faut essayer de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
heureux ceux qui auraient des
explications simples
âge moyen à 17 ans
un tiers de mineur
moins de 10% de personnes de nationalité
non-française
et 60% monsieur le ministre 60% de
personnes inconnues des services de
police même pas un fait mais pas un
usage stupéfiant ou refus d'obtempérer
le contraire de la délinquance
habituelle
sur les 500 villes
politique de la ville
plus de 150 n'ont pas connu des choux
fourrés
et puis il y a une centaine de villes
qui n'ont pas de quartier politique de
la ville et qui ont connu des
échauffourés
donc je crois monsieur le ministre
qu'avant de répondre totalement votre
question si j'évite la politique
politicienne et si je me dis qu'ensemble
on doit travailler pour le bien de la
République pour le bien de notre nation
je crois qu'il faut savoir se poser
quelques temps après avoir établi
totalement le droit public depuis deux
jours les choses sont rétablies j'en
remercie les policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats les élus bien sûr tous ceux
qui contribuent mais que
il faut réfléchir parce que je crois que
dans une belle revue que j'avais lorsque
j'étais adhérent de la même famille
politique que vous il était écrit que
dans les victoires d'Alexandre on y
trouve toujours Aristote
alors
Aristote mais le président caoutchi
mais Aristote n'est pas Platon donc
je vais peut-être pas reprendre
là-dessus chez le ministre
je ne veux pas évoquer tous les sujets
de fond
l'échec de l'école pour des raisons
multiples échec de la politique
d'intégration à laquelle je suis très
attaché pour là aussi des raisons
multiples on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais je le dis très tranquillement avec
l'expérience de mon département bien sûr
mais aussi de tout le pays lorsque ça va
mal ou lorsqu'il y a crise il y a en
réalité de piliers de jambes pour
l'autorité de l'État et l'établissement
la République c'est le Tricolore des
écharpes des élus locaux et le bleu de
nos forces de l'ordre gendarme policiers
police nationale sapeurs-pompiers
ce que nous vous demandons est-ce que
nous demandons à la première ministre ce
n'est pas de faire des miracles parce
que quand on me dit il faut analyser les
raisons de fond oui enfin on les cite
beaucoup depuis 10-15 ans 20 ans mais ce
que nous demandons à la première
ministre à tout le gouvernement c'est de
dire que l'on va restituer aux mers la
politique locale c'est de dire que l'on
va restituer au maire la politique du
logement de l'urbanisme c'est de dire
que l'on a confiance dans nos forces de
l'ordre et ne pas avoir un discours
alternatif ou du en même temps vous
devez incarner l'état l'autorité de
l'État parce que sinon il n'y aura plus
de République
merci
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurent se Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
partager avec les collègues ici présents
et les membres du gouvernement le
malaise que m'inspire le débat public
depuis quelques jours il y a une semaine
un jeune garçon était tué par un
policier dans l'exercice de fonctions
policiers mis ensuite en examen pour
homme ici volontaire et aujourd'hui le
procès qu'instruise certains politiques
et les médias c'est celui des quartiers
prioritaires et des parents qui vivent
nous assistons à une véritable
manipulation fondée sur une part de
mensonge et beaucoup d'ignorance
j'espère non les quartiers prioritaires
ne sont pas inondés de subventions
publiques payées par des bons Français
méritants 6100 euros 6100 euros par
habitant par an dans les quartiers
prioritaires 6800 dans les autres
quartiers dans ces quartiers dans
certains immeubles 40% de mermonaux
parental qui enchaîne deux ou trois
boulots un jour qui garde les enfants
des autres les nôtres souvent et qui ne
peuvent pas faire garder les eaux les
leurs des pères évaporés vous voulez les
poursuivre je suis d'accord avec vous
poursuivons les utilisons ce qui existe
poursuivons-les pour abandon de famille
par exemple et dans les familles ou les
personnes présents vous vous intéressez
à la violence des enfants
intéressons-nous aussi à la violence que
ces enfants ont subi chez eux avec leur
mère et leur père alors madame la
Première ministre aujourd'hui au lieu de
laisser accuser les mers je vous propose
de les aider à survivre à vivre que nous
soutenions leurs associations que nous
les écoutions que nous les émancipions
du clientélisme municipal aussi mise en
sur les mers pour remettre les quartiers
d'aplomb ce serait probablement notre
meilleur investissement
pour vous répondre
la parole
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice
merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs c'est notaire madame
la sénatrice rossignol
je pense qu'on ne veut pas poursuivre
les parents
c'est une caricature que de dire cela
ainsi j'ai d'ailleurs dit moi-même que
n'était pas question à mon avis de
supprimer des allocations je pense en
particulier je pense en particulier aux
femmes qui travaillent qui sont seuls
qui élèvent leur famille
qui le font avec beaucoup de dignité
dans la difficulté je pense aussi à des
parents qui pourraient faire un certain
nombre de choses vis-à-vis de leurs
enfants en particulier assuré l'autorité
parentale et qui ne le font pas vous
voyez dans ces nuits courtes que nous
avons eu les uns et les autres émaillés
de mauvaises nouvelles et de vidéos il y
a une vidéo qui m'a plu c'est celle du
père qui va récupérer son gamin par le
callback et qui lui diront à la maison
parce qu'à 11 ans traîne pas dans les
rues je vous rappelais d'ailleurs que
nous avons tous nos souvenirs enfin pour
ceux qui se sont mariés des dispositions
d'articles 212 du Code civil les époux
se doivent mutuellement fidélité ce
courrier assistant son oublier le reste
les parents ont une obligation morale ça
n'est pas plus compliqué que ça à
l'égard de leurs enfants oui et ceux qui
peuvent et qui ne le font pas méritent
d'être sanctionnés puis il y a une
responsabilité civile qui est très
simple c'est quand les enfants cassent
mais c'est les parents qui paient ça
existe depuis toujours et il faut le
rappeler enfin il y a une autre
responsabilité pénale qui consiste
lorsque l'enfant est convoqué pour les
parents de l'accompagner devant la
justice et s'il ne le fait pas il encore
une amende qui est une amende importante
j'ai rappelé ça j'ai demandé au
procureur de le mettre en oeuvre je
viens à l'attention des parents de
rédiger un flyer voilà c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça qui explique en termes
simple quelles sont les obligations pour
les parents madame la sénatrice qu'il
aurait oublié
madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux je
prends acte du fait que pour vous la loi
suffit aujourd'hui pour protéger les
enfants et poursuivre les parents vous
savez mes chers collègues j'observe
depuis quelques années le monde
politique
les hommes les femmes y compris dans
leur intimité et leur difficulté de
parents laissez-moi finir il y a aussi
chez nous des enfants arrêtés placés en
garde à vue mis en examen et condamné
nos enfants ne sont dit meilleurs ni
pire que ceux des autres pour autant je
vous invite à regarder les autres
parents avec un peu plus d'empathie de
bienveillance ils font comme vous comme
nous comme ils peuvent au mieux
bon la parole est très collègues Arnaud
Bazin pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues la
France entière a appris avec effroi la
tentative d'assassinat à l'encontre de
la famille de Monsieur le Maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent gendre les
Français savent peut-être moins que
Stéphanie vonneux madame le Maire de
Pontoise n'a réchappé d'un traquenard
que d'extrême justesse grâce à son
sang-froid et à la solidité de son
véhicule tire de mortier dans
l'habitacle jette projectile tentative
de la capturer bilan un tympe en détruit
des brûlures à la jambe et l'inévitable
choc psychologique même si elle est fait
même si elle y fait face avec beaucoup
de courage la France ne sait pas en
revanche que 24 heures après l'incendie
de ma mairie de coeur à Persan le
premier adjoint déjà menacé par les
flammes dans le bâtiment la veille a été
réveillé à son domicile par des coups
dans ses volets au cri de on est là on
est là
et je demande pardon à tous les autres
élus qui en ont subi autant de ne
pouvoir tous les citer ici mais je sais
que sur tous ces bandes nous pensons
tous à eux le maire représentant de sa
population et de l'État et maintenant
partout menacé déjà depuis des années le
moindre refus du maire dont le moindre
village pouvait déboucher sur des cris
des insultes démonaces et même des
agressions physiques le maire n'est plus
protégé par l'aura d'autorité de sa
fonction parce qu'il représente l'État
dont trop de nos compatriotes récuse
maintenant l'autorité
l'enfant-roi est devenu un adulte tyran
alors madame la Première ministre
au-delà des quelques mesures que vous
avez déjà en magasin protection
juridique physique statut des élus que
comptez-vous faire pour rétablir à tout
moment et en tout lieu l'autorité de
l'État et donc celle des mères seul vrai
garante de leur sécurité au moment où la
population a tant besoin d'eux
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur basin les violences de ces
derniers jours n'ont pas manqué
d'exposer à nouveau nos élus beaucoup de
nos élus locaux beaucoup de nos mères je
veux souligner ici le courage qui a été
le leur pour défendre leur commune pour
défendre leur ville je veux rendre ici
hommage à celles et ceux qui ont été
agressés très souvent violemment par les
émeutiers j'ai notamment une pensée pour
Monsieur le Maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
Vincent Jean Brun ou de la mère de
Pontoise Stéphanie van le houx Boris
Ravignan son épouse bien sûr
à Vincent Jean Brun et en fait ces
agressions sont tout simplement
ignobles nous n'avons pas manqué de
mesurer aux côtés de madame la Première
ministre leur gravité la première façon
d'assurer la sécurité des élus dans
cette crise a été de déployer 45000
policiers nationaux et gendarmes pour
amener l'ordre les hommages que les élus
leur ont rendu ces derniers jours en
témoignent je veux saluer aussi le
courage de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure de nos pompiers de nos le
secours et de nos policiers municipaux
nous avons voulu répondre aussi à ces
violences du quotidien dès le 17 mai au
moment de la démission de Yannick Morin
nous avons protégé nos élus c'est pas
moins depuis deux mois de 3400 gendarmes
référents violences faites aux élus qui
vont à la rencontre de nos élus locaux
qui vont prendre en compte et couper
évaluer protéger et enquêter 1800 élus
se sont nouvellement inscrits depuis
deux mois sur le dispositif alarme dont
je vous parlais pas moins de trois
plateformes ont été déjà des référencé
face à des cyber violences cette
plateforme farose en jeu vous citez le
mérite il y a quelques semaines une
circulaire du ministre de l'intérieur du
garde des sceaux et de moi-même est venu
rappeler au préfet au procureur que
cette cause est une priorité absolue et
qu'elle appelle une action résolue de
leur part nous voulons aller plus loin
madame la Première ministre annoncé un
plan national de prévention et de lutte
contre les violences qui s'inspirent de
vos travaux et que je vous présenterai
vendredi dans trois jours je vous
remercie j'ai besoin vous avez quelques
secondes
j'espérais comme Roger carotic vous me
répondriez décentralisation pouvoir des
communes pouvoir des mers je suis un peu
déçu mais j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que ce samedi nous risquons de
connaître le même désastre madame panot
vient d'appeler la terre entière à
manifestation entre persan et Beaumont à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire du décès de
Monsieur Adama Traoré je vous engage à
réfléchir à interdire cette
manifestation
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Gérard
Poitiers pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre lors de sa
prochaine visite à Nancy en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin juillet le
président de la République pour avoir
par lui-même comment agrandir le
cocotier qu'il avait planté à OVA avec
Ginette une petite fille Canac de l'île
le 4 mai 2018 dénommé l'arbre de
l'avenir
le gouvernement s'est employé à faire
pousser cet arbre à la de l'avenir sous
votre autorité et celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer vous avez
tracé le cadre celui d'un accord global
et ambitieux la perspective la poursuite
de l'émancipation du pays y compris en
ce qui concerne certaines compétences
régaliennes les fondements les
fondamentaux un peuple calaisonien qui
pense à racine dans une citoyenneté
calédonienne irréversible une nouvelle
calédonie une et indivisible ce qui
inclut toute partition du pays
et un référendum d'auteur de termination
de rassemblement ou de projets au lieu
de référendum binaire comme je le
défendais déjà devant notre assemblée le
4 mai 2021
madame la Première ministre je suis
Canac calédonien et français
je crois plus que jamais au destin
commun entre la France et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie en destin commun
nourri par une histoire une langue une
école et des valeurs mais aussi par une
souveraineté partagée c'est pourquoi le
prochain accord le vrai nous conduire à
fusionner ce qui nous a toujours opposé
jusqu'à lors la souveraineté et la
République madame la Première ministre
confirmez-vous à notre hôte assemblée
que vous êtes prêtes à vous inscrire
dans cette perspective dans le respect
du résultat des trois référendums pour
que vive le peuple calédonien vivent la
Nouvelle-Calédonie vive la france merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs dessinateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Gérard poadja les accords de Matignon en
1988 on manifesté la volonté des
Calédoniens de mettre fin au cycle des
violences
disons plus tard l'accord de Nouméa a
marqué une nouvelle étape
renforçant la prise en compte de
l'identité Canac en fondant de nouvelles
institutions en organisant le transfert
des compétences et en définissant le
calendrier du processus d'exercice du
droit à l'autodétermination
dans le respect des engagements pris en
1998 et sous l'autorité du Président de
la République les trois consultations
référendaires prévues par l'accord de
Nouméa ont été organisés en
2018-2020 et 2021 à trois reprises
lesquelles et deniens ont fait la même
réponse et au soir de la troisième
consultation le 12 décembre 2021 le
président de la République a priacte de
la volonté de la majorité des
Calédoniens de rester dans la République
et dans la nation française
comme vous le savez mon gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour accompagner les
discussions sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au sein de la
République et dans les dans le respect
des acquis de l'Accord de Nouméa le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
Gérald Darmanin a confirmé dans un
récent courrier adressé ou partenaire
politique que les transferts de
compétences réalisés depuis 1998 tout
comme le principe d'une citoyenneté
calédonienne n'avait pas vocation à être
remise en cause
pour autant les conditions d'accès à
cette citoyenneté font d'ores et déjà
l'objet d'échanges avec l'ensemble des
partenaires politiques monsieur le
sénateur je vous confirme que le
prochain accord respectera la volonté
exprimée par la majorité des Calédoniens
je vous confirme que le prochain accord
ne remettra pas en cause le principe du
partage de souveraineté qui est
mentionné dans le préambule de l'Accord
de Nouméa et je forme le vœu que le
prochain accord ne soit pas que
juridique et institutionnel mais
poursuivent l'ambition d'un destin
commun calédonien je suis prête à
inviter l'ensemble des partenaires à la
fin du mois d'août pour un cycle de
réunions Trilatérale qui doit nous
permettre de conclure l'accord que les
Calédoniens attendent c'est bien
évidemment en lien avec Gérald Darmanin
et son équipe Jean-François caraco et
Sonia baquet que nous préparons cette
rencontre je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Muriel jourdat pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
semaines vous adressez au magistrat une
circulaire qui faisait état de la
conduite à tenir lorsque des infractions
étaient commises au cours de
manifestations
immédiatement le Syndicat de la
magistrature qui est plus connu du grand
public depuis une dizaine d'années grâce
aux tristement célèbre mur des cons le
Syndicat de la magistrature adressait
une contre circulaire
qui expliquait en substance comment ne
pas appliquer vos consignes plus
récemment suite aux événements qui ont
animé toute cette séance le Syndicat de
la magistrature publie est un communiqué
intitulé mort de Naël ce n'est pas à la
justice d'éteindre une révolte le
Syndicat de la magistrature y expliquait
dans une sorte de diatribe de quelle
façon il s'opposait au gouvernement il
se posait au syndicat policier et
évoquait des violences policières
je souhaiterais rappeler un principe qui
excitent la liberté syndicale et forte
dans sa liberté d'expression elle
s'arrête là où le statut du magistral
arrête c'est à dire à l'impossibilité de
faire de la politique comment
comptez-vous monsieur le garde des
sceaux rappelait ce principe et le faire
appliquer
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
Garde des sobélis de la justice monsieur
Dupont-Moretti merci madame la sénatrice
de me poser cette question d'abord je
voudrais vous dire sans en bas j'ai de
façon très claire que je partage vos
inquiétudes totalement
le mur des cons il comporte la
photographie de Monsieur escarpin qui a
un tort
c'est d'avoir vu sa fille se faire
assassiner
durant les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle le Syndicat de la
magistrature a dit que c'était un
deuxième tour de cauchemar
et puis le Syndicat de la magistrature
souhaite choisir son ministre
et le Syndicat de la magistrature
souhaite même qu'il n'y ait plus de
ministère de la Justice
j'aurais pu rappeler tout ça mais je ne
le ferai pas mais
je vais en réalité
m'arrêter sur cette fausse circulaire
Canada Dry car elle ressemble à une
circulaire que prend le garde des sceaux
oui elle incite même les magistrats
d'ailleurs à violer les textes de loi
donc j'y vois une forme d'humour en ce
qui me concerne voyez-vous madame la
sénatrice et je ne veux pas aller plus
loin moi je vais vous dire je me bats au
quotidien pas pour le Syndicat de la
magistrature mais pour les magistrats et
pour améliorer leurs conditions et je
vous remercier le Sénat d'avoir voté le
texte que j'ai présenté ici et puis
peut-être une toute dernière chose
je suis le seul à pouvoir prendre une
circulaire de politique pénale parce que
je suis le garde des sceaux et parce que
démocratiquement je vous dois des
comptes ce qui n'est pas le cas du
Syndicat de la magistrature
merci
le garde des sceaux que notre
indignation commune doit sortir de cette
hémicycle et aller au-delà je pense que
dans les temps troublés que nous
connaissons il faut effectivement que
chacun dans son rôle chaque institution
qui est en charge de l'État de droit le
rappel et joue son rôle dans cet état de
droit le pilier de l'État de droit qu'il
a justice ne peut pas critiquer un
punément à notre pilier que sont les
forces de l'ordre l'autorité judiciaire
ne peut pas se transformer en pouvoir
politique et je crois que nous
ramènerons pas l'ordre dans le pays si
nous n'avons pas d'ordre dans nos
institutions
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à notre collègue Annie le
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre de la santé et de
la prévention la nuit dernière j'ai eu
15 patients qui ont fait plus de 60 km
pour venir aux urgences de Rennes chaque
matin on compte 20 à 40 patients qui ont
passé la nuit sur des brancards avec un
risque de surmortalité de 50% faute de
lit avale disponible la solution serait
de laisser les patients attendre dans
les ambulances plus sécurisées mais
alors qui va aller chercher les patients
les transports sanitaires sont aussi
saturés paroles d'urgentiste à Carrel et
service d'urgence sont fermés en juillet
et août alors que la vieille charrue
accueilleront 280000 festivaliers
l'hôpital le plus proche est à 90 km et
1h15 de route la maternité de Guingamp
n'accueille plus les femmes pour
accoucher suspension reconduites 4 mois
faute de personnel épuisée d'avoir tenu
à bout de bois ces services on a
l'impression d'être abandonné en tentant
dans les cortèges de manifestants vous
suspendez les activités des petits
hôpitaux elle se reporte sur les méthode
de référence sur les CHU eux-mêmes
exemples à Pontivy Avranches Les
Sables-d'Olonne dans tous les centres
hospitaliers de France ce sont des cris
d'alarme des médecins en grève hier les
ARS rassurent appel au soignants
éducation des patients régulation
appelez le 15 avant de vous déplacer
mais aucun les équipes n'en peuvent plus
pas assez nombreux les urgentistes
quittent l'hôpital pour des conditions
de travail moins contraignantes la
médecine de ville ne va pas mieux et les
cabinets de consultation remplacent les
cabines de consultation remplacent les
médecins de proximité monsieur le
ministre la situation s'aggrave elle
n’inquiète plus nos concitoyens ni les
élus locaux elle les angoisses quelle
réponse concrète à cette crise aiguë de
l'hôpital public et des urgences dès cet
été soient aujourd'hui
pour vous répondre la parole de temps au
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs et
Center madame la sénatrice le héros oui
nous manquons professionnels de santé le
diagnostic n'est malheureusement pas
nouveau et oui ce gouvernement agit en
formant plus de médecins mais il va
falloir attendre 10 ans en formant
encore plus d'infirmiers plus 6000 plus
d'aide-soignant plus 3000 les fermetures
qui sont souvent pas pour les services
d'urgence simplement des accès régulés
que vous évoquez ne sont pas du fait
d'une décision qui serait économique
mais simplement parce que nous manquons
de professionnels de santé donc la
solution viendra en redonnant plus de
temps à ses professionnels ce que nous
avons commencé à faire et en en formant
plus que nous faisons également
concernant les urgences et vous le savez
c'est une priorité forte encore
renforcée pour cet été vous avez évoqué
un certain nombre de solutions qui sont
mises en place mais ce sont des
solutions mises en place déjà l'été
dernier et qui fonctionne puisque l'été
dernier nous avons diminué de 5% la fré
nos services d'urgence ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas depuis plus de 20 ans
alors ces solutions elles sont autour de
trois axes un premier axe qui est
effectivement l'information de nos
concitoyens sur le bon usage du système
de santé et en particulier le bon usage
des urgences pour lequel avant de se
déplacer si votre médecin n'est pas
disponible oui il faut appeler le 15
parce qu'on vous trouvera la meilleure
solution adaptée en fonction du
territoire où vous êtes et dans ce cadre
là nous renforçons la régulation
médicale nous accélérons le déploiement
de ce service d'accès aux soins qui
intègre des médecins généralistes à la
régulation nous renforçons leur
rémunération nous avons grâce à ce qui a
été voté par le Parlement transformer
les assistants de régulation médicale en
professionnelle de santé permettant là
aussi de valoriser leur exercice et puis
il faut aussi désinfecteurs sur le
terrain c'est le cas en ville plus 15
euros pour les actes qui sont réalisés à
la demande de cette régulation c'est le
cas également au niveau des transports
sanitaires vous en avez parlé ou on
facilite le transport vers les médecins
généralistes et également en renforçant
les communautés professionnelles des pas
peur de santé à l'hôpital nous avons
pris en compte la pénibilité en
augmentant en doublant même l'indemnité
de nuit pour le personnel paramédical en
multipliant par 1,5 pour les médecins
nous travaillons également et nous avons
développé une logique territoriale que
ce soit pour les gardes en associant
public et privé mais également pour la
gestion des lignes dont vous parlez qui
se fait maintenant à l'échelle du
territoire et puis un délai seulement à
l'échelle d'un établissement donc oui
des solutions sont mises en place et
pour certaines elle fonctionne on sait
déjà et pour les autres elle commence à
montrer leur efficacité je vous remercie
le ministre il y a urgence aux urgences
et vous ne répondez pas à cette urgence
c'est parti de la promesse républicaine
on en est loin la défaillance de la
médecine de ville conduit à
l'engorgement des
urgences alors que les limaces en
avalent le système est embolisé où vont
exercer les médecins qui quittent
l'hôpital une remise à plat du service
public de santé s'impose et ce ne sont
pas vos propositions qui régleront le
problème
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
bonus pour le gros Blair républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances plus de 1000 commerces
pillés 250 bureaux de tabac détruit plus
d'un milliards d'euros de dégâts pour
les entreprises ces chiffres sont
édifiants ils auraient pu être encore
plus important ça le travail de nos
forces de l'ordre que nous remercions
la mort d'un jeune de justifie pas les
vagues de violence de pillage auxquelles
nous avons assisté aucun commerce de
l'abri je ne vous cache pas notre
inquiétude et je suis certain que la
partager
ces événements impactent durement les
commerçants des professionnels qui ont
quatre coins du pays vivent dans une
situation de tripes en sécurité
insécurité matérielle d'abord en étant
pas certaine retrouver intact à outils
de travail au petit matin alors qu'il se
battent depuis des années pour le
construire insécurité physique et
psychologique ensuite et pardon et c'est
elle qui angoissée doit faire face à des
situations hors de contrôle et bien sûr
insécurité économique car il n'est pas
certain de pouvoir compter sur la
solidarité des banques et des assurances
en cas de pillage cette triple
insécurité des commerçants le pays le
plus lentement trop longtemps
plus de 50 samedi de blocage dans le
centre-ville avec les gilets jaunes
trois mois de manifestation contre les
réformes de retraite et maintenant une
semaine d'émeutes et tout cela
évidemment conjugué aux autres
difficultés implation crise de l'énergie
et bien sûr la crise de covid et le
remboursement du PGE constitue un
vêtement supplémentaire victime
collatérale de ces événements ils sont
systématiquement parmi les premiers
empires vous ne pouvez pas fermer les
yeux sur la situation de cette phrase
qui travaille qui se bat qui crée et
maintient pour maintenir de l'emploi
elle mérite plutôt que plus que jamais
le soutien de l'État à qui il revient
d'assurer sa fonction régalienne
première la sécurité
les annulations de charge au cas par cas
pour les seuls commerces les plus
touchés ce n'est pas suffisant ils sont
tous touchés directement ou
indirectement et les ont besoin de
mesures fortes quelles mesures durable
envisagez-vous pour soutenir les
commerçants dans ces épreuves ce
ministre
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire
qui est ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur bonus
je tiens aussi
comme vous à remercier les forces de
l'ordre grâce auquel nos commerçants
même si vous l'avez dit plus d'un
millier d'entre eux a été touché
ont pu quand même pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ré-ouvrir je voudrais dans
ces moments difficiles à voir un mot
bien sûr de soutien ça va peut-être vous
étonner un petit mot d'espoir aussi
436 bar-tabac pour être précis ça n'est
pas 250
c'est bien plus 160 d'entre eux
aujourd'hui même sont ouverts et on
recommençait à travailler pas toujours
avec les vitrines nickel mais ils sont
déjà autre retournés au boulot vous
l'avez dit il faut je reprends vos mots
il faut ouvrir les yeux je tiens à vous
dire que Bruno Le Maire et moi-même
avons les yeux grands ouverts ça a été
le cas pendant le covid je pense que
d'ailleurs les commerçants le
reconnaissent l'État a été à leur côté
ça a été le cas et ça l'est encore pour
un certain nombre de difficultés sur les
factures d'électricité et c'est aussi le
cas depuis le début des émeuts dès
samedi nous avons réunis les assureurs
les banquiers dès lundi nous les avons
revu oui il y aura au cas par cas des
annulations de charge oui nous avons
mobilisé les assureurs c'est non pas
cinq jours mais 30 jours que nos
commerçants auront pour reprendre un peu
de souffle faire leur déclaration j'en
profite pour vous dire deux réflexes
vous avez été touché porter plainte
appelez votre assureur nous avons des
commerçants qui pour certains sont
sidérés je tiens aussi à vous que j'irai
impôts.gouv.fr vous avez la liste de
tous les conseillers débarquementaux à
la sortie de crise qui dans chaque
préfecture accompagne nos commerçants
depuis des mois d'ailleurs pour le
problème de l'électricité ces
conseillers départementaux ont
aujourd'hui aussi un soutien
psychologique à la disposition de nos
commerçants on parle beaucoup
d'économies on parle beaucoup de
remboursement ce qu'on m'a dit sur le
terrain avant-hier hier c'est Madame
Grégoire et c'était pareil pour Bruno Le
Maire c'est un soutien psychologique
qu'on a besoin aussi parce qu'on est
sidéré donc sachez juste monsieur venu
qu'on l'intègre et que dans les
préfectures de France avec des
associations on va aussi les accompagner
moralement au-delà de la reconstruction
que ce soit les assureurs les banquiers
le soutien moral et psychologique nous
n'ayez pas de doute nous serons à leur
côté aujourd'hui et dans la
reconstruction qui est devant nous merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur bonus
vous avez quelques secondes
merci merci Madame la Ministre sachez
que on doit se préparer aux autres aux
autres événements malheureusement et et
si ça devient un redondant et de subir
comme ça chaque fois c'est c'est plus
qu'un boissant et je crois que c'est une
prise de conscience collective et il
faut il faut tous mobiliser c'est trop
dur ça devient trop compliqué merci
beaucoup merci
avant de donner la parole je souhaite
saluer notre collègue Bernard bonne qui
va prendre la parole qui a décidé lui et
bien
de nous quitter le premier octobre et de
pas renouveler son mandat à la suite de
son action comme président du Conseil
général de la Loire je voudrais rappeler
ce qu'il a fait au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales notamment sous la
question du grand âge il a été le
rapporteur avec Michel meunier de la
mission d'information sur le contrôle
des EHPAD l'an dernier un vrai sujet de
société majeure que la place du grand
âge dans notre société je voulais le
remercier d'avoir éveillé nos
consciences sur ce sujet
[Applaudissements]
si monsieur le Président merci monsieur
le Président ma question justement
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
Solidarités et du grand âge et cela fait
des années monsieur le ministre quand
nous annonce une loi grand âge
séparait-il comme beaucoup d'autres une
priorité du gouvernement depuis 2017
manifestement il n'y aura pas de grands
soir puisque le 4 avril dernier vous
avez annoncé je reprends vos termes que
cette réforme se ferait en plusieurs
briques soit j'aurais préféré pour ma
part parler d'une fusée à plusieurs
étages mais ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
la fusée a bien du mal à décoller
la ppel bien vieillir examinée à
l'Assemblée nationale en avril dernier
n'apporte pas toutes les réponses
attendues mais elle a été enrichie de
mesures concrètes positives
la poursuite de son examen est alors du
jour je m'en réjouis mais il faudra
attendre encore de longues semaines
avant qu'elle ne soit examinée au Sénat
pendant ce temps suite aux travaux d'une
fabrique du Bien Vieillir modèle dans le
cas du CNR vous deviez nous annoncer
début juin un plan d'action détaillé qui
ne relève pas de la loi nous attendons
toujours monsieur le ministre et puis
tout le monde le sait le nerf de la
guerre c'est le financement le troisième
étage devrait être donc être à l'examen
du belfss à l'automne car c'est le
rapport Libaud qui le dit et qu'il
affirme près de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an seront
nécessaires dès 2030 pour financer la
dépendance alors Monsieur le Ministre
quand donc allez-vous alimenter le
moteur de cette fusée et répandra ainsi
aux attentes de nos concitoyens et des
professionnels du secteur
pour vous répondre la parole
Jean-Christophe con mini des solidarités
de l'autonomie et des personnes
handicapées Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Bernard bonne alors
permettez-moi de profiter de votre
question pour à mon tour saluer le
travail remarquable et reconnu de tous
que vous avez effectué ici au Sénat tant
dans le secteur de la protection de
l'enfance que dans celui du grand âge
engagement que nous partageons
aujourd'hui alors vous m'interrogez
justement sur la question de la
politique du grand âge j'aurais un
regret manifestement c'est de nos
discussions de ne pas avoir réussi à
vous convaincre que la politique résolue
déterminée du gouvernement était dépassé
très largement l'ambition et le champ
d'un grand projet d'un grand projet de
loi grand âge vous savez on agit avec
une double temporalité celle de
l'urgence et l'année dernière lorsque
j'étais nommé ministre vous m'avez
présenté avec Michel meunier vos
conclusions sur la question du contrôle
des EHPAD et on a travaillé ensemble à
l'inscription d'un certain nombre de
mesures dans le cadre du projet loi de
financement la sécurité sociale pour
assurer la transparence la moralisation
du secteur ramenait de la confiance et
puis on a travaillé également sur des
mesures d'urgence pour soutenir un
secteur qui en grande difficulté
économique aujourd'hui on y travaille
avec les agences régionales de santé et
avec les départements au quotidien pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas de
défaillance concernant la réforme du
grand âge je vous l'ai dit ce qui fera
foi c'est la feuille de route que je
vais présenter prochainement qui est
issu des conclusions du CNR du Conseil
national de la refondation dédiée aux
bien vieillir qui a conclu le 4 avril et
qui visera à adapter notre société au
vieillissement à relever ce défi du
vieillissement de la société c'est une
feuille de route interministérielle
parce qu'elle concerne aussi les
transports elle concerne le logement
elle concerne notre système de santé
elle concerne aussi les comportements
individuels dans ce que on pourra porter
en matière de prévention pour assurer un
vieillissement en bonne santé
on travaillera à la question de la
citoyenneté et du lien social bien
vieillir ce vieillir aussi en lien on
travaillera à la question de la
transformation évidemment de l'offre
médico-social tant en établissement que
à domicile et donc c'est tout ça que je
porterai dans cette feuille de route qui
se déclinera dans la proposition de loi
du Bien Vieillir pour ce qui relève de
la loi ou pour ce qui concerne les
financements dans le cadre de la loi de
finances et de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour l'année
prochaine je suis bonne
oui merci monsieur le ministre je
m'attendais bien à une réponse de ce
type mais quand même la loi grand âge
est importante et je ne doute pas de
votre volonté de faire aboutir cette loi
ainsi que son financement mais je crains
faire que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez ne soit pas aussi volontaire
et décidés
ont le droit de vieillir dans la dignité
nous le leur devons bien merci
nous avons terminé avec les questions au
Gouvernement les prochaines questions au
gouvernement aura lieu le mercredi 12
juillet à 15h je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h35 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi
visant à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique la séance est suspendue